okay guys it's your boy psychobabble and
we are back playing they'll walk in ten
actually uh we're not back yet
let me move okay perfect perfect okay
we're back
um let's do this you're walking dead the
final season this has all been a
super-good serious telltale is oh I
don't know if when it comes something um
you know their game sometimes it just
looks like they just grabbed the latest
bandwagon I'm just like poor D until I
go game but this one has been really
good
unlike like the actual show that's kind
of a little too crazy with like like I
don't know every seasons like good
starting over with I gotten the
community this has been pretty constant
so let's do this the first episode well
I went out is done running so let's do
this captain's is on no I won't be
yeah that tape
oh yeah display this place up how's that
oh my god
there we go when dad started walking
until a man named Lee became my
protector he was a dick that much was
certain he was a deck the only hand
scared him more than that dad was being
nice she died I think he died did other
people too
[Music]
you remember I can't sing so Carly
a woman in our group named Lily lost her
dad yes that was very true boom let
there be higher over that
on the side of the road how to survive
he protected me as long as he could she
bit him had nothing to do with zombies
let's go really infected they you know
stay in the city
I really cannot remember this this isn't
way back you know what we Ross washed up
he made one final request
he asked me to shoot him oh yeah I think
I did yeah whoa that another group after
that broken people running from their
past there was a woman who gave birth to
a boy named Alvin jr. oh yeah AJ he made
it but the mom didn't okay and I started
to take care of him
but then Jane left AJ in the snow we
thought he was gone forever that was the
last straw for Kenny without and he was
crazy we shot it turned out AJ was alive
Jane hit him to make a point knowing
what they'd done
I still decided we were better together
for AJ sake
I like everything else I think the clip
to continue is when like the Texas age
to a new frontier
I thought we'd found something that
worked but I was wrong again pretty good
from me said I was too young to take
care of them
I fought back but I wasn't strong enough
I searched for a long time
just when I gave up hope
I found him say god I'm banking together
now
okay okay the game series adapt so the
choices I make like okay paid my car
Bell yeah so hope that doesn't really
affect things but you never know with
these things they're pretty telltale is
pretty immersive oh that's disgusting
it's so wet
look we were they up their graphics in
this one actually it looks like a game I
don't know oh it's me
hey Batman she drives out
whoa just play with your test you're
doing there goofball pretend oh we got
bullets
oh don't it's getting on my nerves
you gonna kill her
and to bid for it
huh so I guess you're all grown up now
yep let me drive I'm not letting you
drive
that's very old and a shirt I guess
people stop making surance what's wrong
AJ hernia yeah such a ballet
I'll eat that pickle gift or get
magazine give him that toy to hate hey
there Alvin jr. it's me
disco broccoli word on the street is
that you want to eat me is that true
do you want to eat me on I can't eat a
toy man my feelings are hurt my stomach
hurts
sorry I only get that bag of chips here
practice your reading wanna it'll take
your mind off your stomach
place cream
Nilla beans into a saucepan and bring to
a boy - chef I'm gonna make you hungrier
I want to give us what about you Ali
thank you I find something else soon I
believe you mm-hmm your first mistake
sister
so dirty
they're really up the graphics on this
one OB okay we're gonna do it we're
gonna do it we're doing it we're doing
it baby yeah yeah okay okay
friendly ring bell no trespassing
anytime I see no trash but I think I
would go make so much noise because
that'd be like they're gonna shoot me in
sewing okay what is this
should I get it a crowbar or should I
get the squeaky toy we're gonna meet
this girl boy I don't need no water oh
great and and we need that toy
anyhow in there I guess that's it inside
a southern chic you know think a burr in
my ah they have a burr in like my shorts
from like walking around its fans I'm
fab a bang let's find some fed yeah this
is weird this is like an RPG now what
the hell I feel like this is really
weird
can I tell this bra did that bro I got
this brown
you know always kill them every time
it's down still with me still here no
bites get in there
chenna that's over here real quick check
it that ain't ler mmm interesting
okay look at here now
hey monster trap it's not a trap you
swing on it for fun yeah yeah try oh he
does want to try okay very smart
all work and no play makes Jack a dull
boy yeah actually make sure this guy's
no food on him
it's tricky disgusting
are you dead in here oh now you are in
shrink water
oh this is a water system
[ __ ] that's it okay need to look at him
in first who's in there
shifting cute okay it's simply too hard
I feel like I can do that
inside a new place checkpoints that's
right mm-hmm AJ's always another thing
huh monsters all tied up they can't get
it there can disgusting I got a call
No you can't they can't get us but
doesn't mean I can't get them windows
are all boarded up
security door hmm can't pry that open I
know you're hungry I am to find
something I promise
mmm-hmm enter the ticket at birth
look at them
poison did they give up
so romantic
well we have a home
please leave us alone
is what we wanted
okay
do we get the key
mmm it's risky might be another way
through that door let's look around
let's be smart
that's right yeah let's be smart smart
this is Kayla
to smell the crawl-through well me
the key of the window those are our
options
it's dark
we should kill the monsters
they're not people
brah
and as people they asked to be left
alone so what's best
we gotta do the wind up bad bang my god
I did that one no sand AJ and I need
your help on this one in there
you bet your ass in there he's obviously
not gonna die
okay can we breathe
let Mia
once you're through unlock this door
huh AJ you've gotta see this
discotek pads everywhere tons and tons
of codex pads
huh they had a good thing going here can
we stay here we'll see yeah no one's
here no one's ever anywhere it's always
just monsters I'm here kiddo
yeah that is what you mean sucker that's
what it sure sounds like it is a good
shot that's right save the last bullet
inspect this can Oh
look
something under here [ __ ] [ __ ] cuz
something else yeah
that wanted to hide something
yes press that's Cuba okay whoa Donna
it is nice yeah that guy's right that
we gotta go buy things
you know what to do stick to the sides
and be my eyes while I clear a cat okay
do this
all right this time
come on come on Kenneth dead you're
gonna eat him
you just got ate sucker Q this dude
yeah yeah key his eyeball
so I'm like yeah they're everything Ulis
lighting I bought you that we've got to
start the car town
oh there's a guy said ding in his mouth
yeah
see that
that guy has like oh the keys are in his
eyeball yeah you like that you start the
key with this is no really okay we got
should get them
if I get those keys baby
come on baby come on baby
this guy's gonna come to them with no
matter what
if you have kill him cue him
sure
I tried to kill him I really try to kill
him but I couldn't do it I didn't send
enough Q's his way
that is a spec date disgusting
[Music]
and I said really
where's the music well you've gotta go
to zero say that cuz we have really got
to monetize the hell out of this
there's no music you don't get music
because if you did music I don't get
paid okay so there's no music sorry
sorry
okay well me a dance right you owe me
let me sing for you huh
you know you want some music credit Oh
DDO ya sit a man extinct it was I was
broken at me in the tutor yeah yeah yeah
I'm singing the song for you
yeah yeah music my Jarrett - yeah yeah
the casing in this song leaves yes it
was a nice flower though Walking Dead
telltale series if I don't see that okay
that's fine I guess
see what is next music wise I'm back
I'm like 80 years older like so much
older
okay
it's great Kathy Klein our keneley let's
do this hey jacket where are you
oh my god I'm chained up this is so
[ __ ] out like Oh Ben think I'm
painting I could tear it off what do you
think I can't do everything in this game
she can't tear it off without me doing
it that's really sad I'm gonna make
choices not to like work okay it's a
really good question it's a really good
question um let's see here a lot of
lights a lot of a lot of good evening so
meet the bleeding I need these pencils
get out of my way I need to open a shore
Oh God memories this is so personal I
think they could be getting this
personal siblings best buddies BFFs not
me I notice I'm not in here that's fine
again I didn't guess I didn't expect to
be friends that fast so I'm not hurt and
it's fine
um let's see here don't there's like
tissues I can look at Oh first it kid
yeah give me some of the hydrogen
peroxide and shake it up the water
my head hurts too much to think about it
look at scrapbook what can I get again
I'm backing out nice I can't keep my
eyes on it like I'm not mad Jen didn't
put me in there it's fine I don't really
care about that okay it's open this
closet maybe gets hopefully something
maybe not from this season but least
from last season you know like oh my god
wait you gotta get that fishing buddy
that a fishing rods I think where's that
I got tackle box or is that me examine
this box not gonna reach it but good
thing they showed me that chair right
there if it didn't I'll be like is be
like impossible looking for it
press W to push yeah I knew it I was
like it's not gonna be this easy it's
like there's no way it's gonna be this
easy that the chair would just push
itself okay yeah now get examine it
again okay it's fine yeah just open it
little at all
oh yes do that'll do Pig they'll do
palette knife sharp enough I'll get bars
Oh God this is prison hell am I tell
really good question and nobody really
knows the answer to that
okay can I open this box now not look at
scrapbook can you give me that choice
[ __ ] I'm getting out of here
it's late plays back is hey melon was
here I'm alone was what
we got to come
whoever it is kill them
come
now
we're not gonna hurt you we've got your
boy he's safe now
kill him kill him
let's make it you lower yours all over
mine
count of three
what
to
good
that's good
see
good circumstances I'll let this little
standoff slide okay yeah I guess I guess
look I'm sorry I didn't know where I was
or who you were I just want to see the
boy I was with just ask what does he
look like we're in pretty rough shape
when we found you take precautions no
just in case you're safe now
so he's a friend Marlon that's Tennessee
Marilyn antenna say 10 for short he's
won been taking care of you
Clementine
come on cleanse let's see this bye-bye
me
let's see him
that's not my boy it's a forest oh okay
there's more
thank goodness been surviving out there
a while huh yeah we've been on the road
a long time take it you know how to
handle yourself yeah I usually see
people our age alone out in the wild
sure I do what I can to get by no matter
what don't worry about it you all do
what we have to
see Martha rules
it's good we found you when we did
wasn't easy getting you out of that
wreck
the car is totaled yeah boy jeez they're
gonna [ __ ] scare crap get away from
me hi I guess is a [ __ ] guy what's
his problem
you just knew haven't seen anything like
you and be miss what is this place
you'll probably tell it used to be a
school now it's who's in charge well I
am probably sounds strange kids run by
kid ourselves
thank you good walls the defense's good
location too
no one really comes out this way hmm
only kids that actually sounds kind of
awesome do you think so I like it myself
but I'm probably a little biased isn't
always like he's like oh cool thanks to
bully yeah
allow me to make it formal welcome to
Erickson's boarding school for troubled
youth your boy like you both fit that
description
it's hard to survive too long these days
without being I was pretty good as a kid
before everything changed a lot of
trouble since boy it's been a little
terror since he arrived excuse me okay
here's like my pro buy something helpful
kids inside with Louis Louis oh right
just listen for the music you'll find
him [ __ ] is that
you look at [ __ ] think
okay save what's in here
follow the music check
I said no music how am I supposed to
monetize this
pakkun all people I'm not wearing pants
PhD in s
good back here hidden treasures for
people not to spend their time hey guys
nice still just Elam
hmm nope music sounds like it's coming
from this floor
it sounds like a really bad mashed up
version doors open
beat her up
he's a good kid you must have provoked
him on the show I'm gonna beat her up
all right she's target overall we got a
killer we got a killer
Sammy code a worser she gone as a friend
I mean I don't pay taxes here yeah
property taxes on this [ __ ] no damn it
I ain't paying it now there is
ain't gonna do hey JD you like [ __ ]
bit someone new I talked about that and
you know we could just talk about that
later
you don't need to talk about that now
he's gonna [ __ ] vomit I like Tiffany
motive a lot of it so I got the chief in
tickle monster says you bid her is that
true
I'm sure she didn't mean to scare you
I'm sorry AJ she snuck up on I didn't
want to hurt I know you did no more
bites
AJ we'll remember that yeah that's good
watch the kid for you whoop it back my
name is agent excuse me
hope he didn't cause you any trouble he
was a bit of a handful but I got off
flight
AJ doesn't like people coming up behind
him don't ever do it don't do it bro Wow
in clear
I'm Lois music is it all right yeah
don't worry I've got it
yeah oh my god that's little Sebastian
baby
oh my doctor's can't
double um does he know what that is it's
telling yeah maybe
dude that can't be a great idea brows
bigger than him is it actually loaded
yes oh good
my gun so it's my rules our our gun just
when you think you've seen it all you
guys do your thing I guess damn straight
ma you don't know any others well there
is one but you're armed
[Music]
stop now do you think we're telling him
it is not always compress this key press
the key AJ you're embarrassing me
you like that thank Anya now press this
one they gave me someone over there I
think get to get on this one okay again
okay again the lighter Hank but okay I
guess it really nice bidam
got a bit of a situation out there you
bet yeah better bike let's get some
asses in gear not on a gear but in the
gear let's go let's go
Rosie where the hell is she
you give her weapon back good we're
gonna need you to put it to use you've
got a hunting party out there trying to
get back inside explosion whoa it's kind
of a deck just saying something you got
a prom [ __ ] we got to finish her off
hello I do not like other girls eyelid
nice to meet you what he said all right
come on
you got it bro
she grows on you I promise I don't like
things occur on me Cheerilee I call it
Cheers
okay that's fine I need you to watch my
back call out from inside if you see
anything cool okay on the other side but
I'm taking a chair so silly you know are
they gonna get that chair they got taken
I think they are taking it second
session focus on this apocalypse who
kill the walkers yeah yeah got it baby
you got it
I forgot I gotta break him up I think
yeah the game
what are you ended it right there I need
you to watch my back call up from inside
if you see anything cool okay see you on
the other side
music on the ground over there we're by
yes
yeah nice one baby let this bread that
what yeah but I ain't gonna drag this
thing all the way back up
you get them
oh yeah okay I guess it's just a bad
idea
whoa this game is a lot harder than last
time
let me tell you
look easy at the watch out with people
like sneaking up on you okay did it
freeze okay come on come on
wait got this way got this
okay yep and thank you
it's harder than this game it's actually
a game play
yes they do Presley like those would be
[ __ ] by you're a loser okay
everything you do is for attention I
hate other females because I'm the alpha
female
I'd kill five right now is that [ __ ]
the buzz ring
okay I left [ __ ] away Sahara like that
they're all like balding piece of [ __ ]
therefore this Debra hmm we always gotta
get the [ __ ] is this pitbull that is
like one of those horrifying things I've
ever seen you know [ __ ] is that
hey see you and Rosie are making friends
had a bad experience with the dog whines
well Rosie here can help you get over
she's as cuddly as they come oh except
when she's mauling walkers
okay just walk them behind you you're
not the only one a lot of cursing in
this one angry a seam I'm gonna get you
he's all right why's worse B - then now
Clem here that was a solid
Hey a + e don't be jealous by be better
yep I'm pretty much a badass and she's
modest do the wonders never cease was
your mouth would cease we kicked
nineteen kinds of Walker ass and was
styled why not be proud value the worst
I hope he gets finished off really
quickly
well
they're pretty good
with the monsters come on y'all Oh
behind him thing about that
painful thing he can't go around
punching people in the same table I'll
talk to him he's biting people name
people what's that bird stop that birds
a crow in school they told us they're
called scavengers badgers Jerris [ __ ]
what it means they don't hunt like us
they just eat stuff that's already dead
scavengers are gross oh yeah I didn't
mean to hit him I didn't know that it
was Marvin Marlin right Marlon Brando
sure they'll forgive you
but we should go talk to them
but I don't think they like ya cuz you
[ __ ] bet done they don't they don't
know you AJ I'll bet when they do like
me just as much as I do
Marlon was really mad yeah you know
she's a [ __ ] she's a jerk
listen we haven't eaten for days
the car is gone all that's outside these
walls are walkers do you really want to
go back out there no so we should
apologize to Marlon that's right now yes
I can work up to it let's talk to the
other kids first [ __ ] down its gonna
Marlon have a gin dick friends okay
anyways a little [ __ ]
I like her
well that's wrong right there no I'd
like I seem either okay Clementine right
yep
the sim right hmm like diary
those who do not learn from the past you
seemed really mad at Marlon back there
he keeps pulling back to safe zone we
have fewer and fewer places to hunt
which means we're gonna have fewer and
fewer things to eat the new girl went
and helped the hunting party come back
she hey that is not yours to read kid
did it back it was just sitting there so
AJ give it back to him okay okay bang
thank you this thing is the only place I
get any real
god preserve what I can you know I got
to finish this before dinner not to be
like
my [ __ ] dick he thinks it would get
me the deck No
yes hey guys web AJ this is Omar excuse
me chef
hello and no it's not ready yet Omar's a
perfectionist slightest flavor out of
place and he's grumpy for a week you can
either you can eat right all it'll cost
you is a little patience okay Jesus
look at Nick it's having hi over there
no that's that weirdo kid no no it says
[ __ ] here's that girl it's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I'm gonna talk to her that's a record a
say I'm sorry yes
scary always seemed so mad you can do it
you just go - he just got of well she
was pretty mad so you just gotta lay it
on thick thick what's that mean be super
duper sorry and super duper nice
yes I I like your shoes
thank you and your hair okay and and you
have a nice voice uh-huh
and your hair is really
red I know and red is my favorite color
are you feeling okay I'm SuperDuper
sorry that I big I see you're forgiven
thank you what oh [ __ ]
you sure did she's a jerk Belle can I
yell her thanketh the [ __ ] out here
I'm not ready oh my god
okay let's talk to someone else
and the [ __ ] is less
violet what a [ __ ] what a [ __ ] hey
guys
I thought has been hurva like either
could you guys didn't have the best
introduction wasn't my fault
ten did you really ought to be more
careful
kind of we just ii like that's his [ __ ]
i'm gonna really this is where we buried
ten sister's belongings mini and sophie
twins Boston
paying respects so I don't like you
maybe one dude hey I think I'd be a very
nice thing to do AJ just do it AJ let's
do it okay
[Music]
thank you
Clemmy yeah I'm ready
right now I find our way okay
yes
oh brother
that's sweet figured there ain't a lot
of room for sweetness still out there
I'm the lucky one
he's just naturally good naturally good
that's rare stuff
are you really sorry I hate can we
please stay here and eat dinner and not
go out into the forest and get killed by
monsters hey don't sweat buddy make it
up to me by teaching me your technique
you regular heavyweight oh very nice
[Music]
guys earn your supper after all
yeah that were weird out yet no [ __ ]
that I don't like this guy little too
charismatic so now that sire
okay
goodnight Ruby very sad huh
hmm Wow sorry buddy I'm sure they share
it as much as they could
AJ heads up
I'm full kettle you can have the rest
are you sure man this mess is trying to
get yanked mm-hmm me too
know what I'll tell you what time for
something very important
Oh God yes I think we're pouring out our
thick cards you playing cards you're
just like you've given up like the only
game is get ready losers it's time for
you all to lose oh I like that
um true talk
it's easy everyone gets a stack of cards
we're gonna [ __ ] cheater
what about AJ [ __ ] laugh looks like
he's made a friend
you take your eyes off there's one card
game both could use break from each
other
yeah maybe this is his first time around
anyone his own age sometimes he acts
more like an adult and a kid huh it's
nice to see him act like a little boy
again yeah I would say so
do I get the [ __ ] cheater
what is this now you were in if I can
last
way to go me so about AJ where are a
Jays parents
you two don't really look related
nothing for business [ __ ] Oh everything
like that okay I win then by the way
he's such a [ __ ] horse eyeballs looks
cantaloupe leg once
[ __ ] I'm kidding are you
this is come great come on spit it out
whoa whoa you can ask me if I've ever
had a girlfriend I have it by the way
never not even once never
I win
so
what what do you want this entire time
we used to take care of it grammar
anyone know it's a paint though I had
people everyone we had adults here oh I
had people and now I don't
well I'm talking pest second actor
disabled I went again you do indeed
ask away worst injury you ever saw
I saw Walker get hit and head so hard
both his eyeballs flew out truthful I
saw someone had their intestines pulled
I think I saw that this isn't that funny
ouch hmm he deserved it
victory violence here's something I'd
love to ask when I'm in groups out of
the four of us what do you think is
gonna die first
violet probably just ask your damn
question [ __ ] actually ask
ever had to kill someone who loved
absolutely babe a Louis me his name was
Lee it was the same day I found out my
parents were dead
that sounds like a rough day worst day
of my life okay I think I'm done playing
for tonight yeah
thank tap game you wanted me to ask
let's go AJ
good night night AJ
long day huh yes I would say that he's
my best friend
let's relax some sleep okay good morning
come find me and talk about making this
long-term we can stay we can talk about
you know hey Yesenia no jailhouse meal
whoa [ __ ] prison cell again that
looks like a really safe window it does
good it's happy
this box has so many colors
well must have been an artist living in
here what's an artist it's got a stretch
[Music]
none of mine no it's fine honestly it's
just been sitting here for the past year
and though he's touched in if AJ wants
to play with it it's it's fine it's AJ's
now it's all right she says you can keep
it yes but get the [ __ ] out of here no
one wants you here yeah okay sure bye
get out of here yeah what's up he's dead
now so I get that [ __ ] out of here okay
not like Lewis though she had actually
she had the most amazing voice real
bluesy I always joked that he would
scavenged a guitar and the two of them
would tour the country that was a long
time my train of thought that's ain't
[ __ ] I don't know why I brought them up
they're gone it's no use reminiscing
about [ __ ] that isn't gonna change get
the [ __ ] out of here just like they went
scavenging with Marlon booty out past
the safe zone didn't make it back it
happens
why'd they [ __ ] like the same
variously I just miss having someone
around to talk to there's just so many
dudes this place can get a little too
broke down for my liking sometimes and
I'm not exactly like a people person you
know kind of have a habit of being a
little bit too harsh it's not like I'm
trying to be BFFs or whatever sorry
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] whoa hey Klum I'm an
artist now
not bad you don't don't you like it
whoa whoa [ __ ] dick the [ __ ] out here
violet lock the lock the doorway on you
yeah I can't [ __ ] [ __ ] stick she can
come in here like whatever my friend
like no okay for claim to make a home
that's a good idea
AJ yeah taper how about here
oh yeah been through
oh that's cool AJ see how easy they
don't leave it just are in there there
is you know [ __ ] what are you doing over
there hey there what are you doing this
is where I know it's safe under here no
one can get well it's safe out here -
did you see the size of this place it's
huge and there are plenty of brick walls
to keep us safe what about the door what
if someone comes in what if they try to
hurt us what if they still are stuck
I'll keep watch I'll sleep with one eye
open if I have to you can't sleep like
that
I tried if I stay here no one can find
me and I can keep guard and watch over I
can protect us Hey what's gotten into
you
please Clem it's not so bad down here
I'll be okay I promise
let's get the rest the better chance
soft and warm I think you'll really like
it
yeah well [ __ ] get in there
this bed is really soft would you so
she's gonna like kill down goodnight AJ
Clem what trying to sleep this place is
nice
I'm glad we found you
nitu
yeah
another round
I like it running he's gonna let us stay
right I guess we're gonna find out let's
find his office I know where it is I'll
show you whoa okay this way climb AJ
wait up wait up AJ
ten to ten memory take all your [ __ ]
pencil night he's my pissed just looking
for crowns what are you guys doing yeah
it's any either these guys [ __ ] a
firefighter that the [ __ ] is a policeman
yeah here's an I want the fact they
[ __ ] dad dad I've never seen they're
still out there someday maybe you'll
meet 100 would turn it to ten what the
[ __ ] you little [ __ ] AJ a [ __ ] smack
you what the [ __ ] was that about
thanks bro ten will remember that that
was insane he just went straight ghetto
okay that'd be nice
Thanks
[Music]
hey what'd you find let's take his
crayons take his pencils take his
pencils there's so little whoa Wow
they've known each other a long time huh
I said a walker [ __ ] is that
is that where being Arlen I'm not gonna
Mouse not gonna miss talking terrify you
though I swear
Rosie's not as driving as she seems sit
girl
bad pet she's harmless
she just needs to get to know you is all
can I better yeah
sure you Erika's chaos me hey gasps okay
I guess Oh late I'll lay it out Oh late
tell Elena
what do you [ __ ] bites on my hand now
whistle tell her to lie down lie down
Rosie that was all muscle [ __ ]
that's so cool see not so hard yeah that
was pretty cool now Rosie will recognize
you okay she's really well-trained
she was the Headmaster's dog back when
this place was still functional
yes ii thank what a dick understand the
century now it's just us kids left and
I'd like it if you
here the ground or rolls hey Jake it's
all tents
father stays in a cage we are starting
to run short
select an object that's us the
greenhouse oh yeah oh don't get too
excited about that one
we used to maintain it real well plenty
of vegetables drawn but it became
overgrown
we keep away from that now
and didn't realize how much forest
surrounds this place it's how we've kept
ourselves from unwanted attention for so
long
that's the only road that leads in and
out of Ericsson you go off it you'll
eventually end up in the valley you step
signs that let people to the school but
okay what's out here oh that's where we
fish shack for storage right here
right along the river it's secure mostly
the occasional Walker to come by mine
Brody should be heading up there in
second mine
what's the trap area hunting grounds
mark where's they [ __ ] don't go here
some traps out there to catch game penis
amber said to go check them today that's
the train station there was a whole
stash of food under the floorboards oh
he crashed your car pretty sure that
place is lost cause
Walker sweat it in there after all
annoys me one more thing
see these red lights yeah so everything
inside isn't safe it's getting smaller
over the years more scarce safe
I'm worried if I don't figure something
out but I don't fix our food situation I
can't
so much friends siblings
dai I get it I know how it feels to lose
a friend yeah oh [ __ ]
and [ __ ] star having uh me to step
the leader they need me to be and really
want to be there for you and AJ or two
more mouths to feed
okay so what do you need from us Luis
sent us and we're heading to the hunting
grounds looking for rabbits
violate and Brody going upriver to use
some spearfishing hopefully was to get
along long enough to get some work done
both teams could use some extra hands
let's go hunting do some hunting do some
hunting
take this Thanks need all hands on deck
just remember to stay in the safe zone
so that means we could stay maybe well
thank you Dad I'm AJ all right let's get
going
see you around
hunting grounds are usually cleared
walkers sometimes they get caught in the
snares and [ __ ] though you see a ribbon
on a tree
traps are nearby okay take me so Callen
here so watch where you step please I
think I can handle myself
I'm basically a ninja hey this guy
martial arts oh you too me too
oh my god I do not like I say oh ouch
someone's a little jealous and my
defense I totally get things done so you
know don't sweat the technique what you
do to survive that's all that matters oh
whatever man you act like you're the
only one with a strategy
you gotta have plans BCD
and what if you don't make it that far
shut up a second
that [ __ ] is that
he's caught in a trap it spinning out of
time [ __ ]
ghetto
hey check this guy out
he's like a walker pinata cut it down
fix the smear and let's go oh well I
will eventually if you want food for the
kid I could use a hand or you can mess
around with this idiot and start
something it's [ __ ] Adam honey so
dramatic I seem did
come to hunt yeah
yeah let me help you out thanks for
taking this [ __ ] seriously I'll never
understand that idiots well I kind of do
like I seem probably [ __ ] can i [ __ ]
that you get shot yeah good I'll chase
him out of the bush
you shoot last time I was out here it
looked like one of the rabbits had some
babies infanticide it's kind of [ __ ]
up Oh [ __ ] whoo I got him gonna need
a few more like this if we're hoping to
eat though I saw some others run this
way okay you want me to come outside
[ __ ]
yeah don't worry about it better to save
our ROV
Clem Clem come here
[ __ ] I want to get a second one [ __ ]
missed
it's a baby
we got it out not enough release it let
it get bigger so my butt will be even
hungrier tomorrow if we don't let him go
yeah we got a lot of we're are you gonna
do it let it go Brown watch AJ Yeller
got better
really what are we supposed to eat
tonight then uh I get it I wouldn't want
to kill a baby bunny either he'll thank
me in a few months if we live that long
all right well the snares have all been
reset and are ready to trap things
you're good to go now or what is that
some more per I'm gonna be late tonight
I'll take this back you should meet up
with Brody and violet and see if they've
managed to snag and fish this isn't
gonna be enough for the whole school
I like fish
that's my okay
do you like fish I once ate a whole
shark yeah you're the [ __ ] liar he
didn't eat a shark this is way too big
can't get a whole shark you're human
you're just like no way unless it's like
a baby shark you know I may be incorrect
ready hungry it's out yeah disgusting
where's van birdy there are now Flynn
look
the [ __ ] is that
why wouldn't have just left this out in
the open wait they're [ __ ] in there
are they [ __ ] in there not great the
curves are gonna demolish us now we
might not be alone
we got a Cove I read kilowatt are there
hooking up
it's clear
it's a fire god I [ __ ] took it maybe
if I took it she's done you can't even
count is stubby Clementine what the hell
happened in here do any of the kids
smoke nope nothing there are the [ __ ]
thieves take a second take the soup
Nicole okay excuse me you guys figure it
out [ __ ]
let's go outside the safe zone
the train station it's not too far from
here I don't know that's pretty far
outside our perimeter there was food in
there when AJ and I passed through it's
worth a look you sure there was food
positive yeah some of it was destroyed
the explosion but there has to be
something left there was so much there
all right oh my eyes
she was kind of a [ __ ]
there that's where the food is a lot
more walkers than last time now
mmm-hmm it's either die here or die from
hunger take your pick
Glenn maybe you should scope things out
you know the place better yeah let me
get a closer look
can't be too careful
get the walkers attention they do like
to follow us out no [ __ ]
you've got an idea the noise from that
Bell could draw a lot of walkers if one
of us climbs up there and starts ringing
it
Louis Louis I'd like to make a
suggestion pilot you're loud dramatic
annoying you're basically a walking
distraction I think you mean charming
and theatrical okay Prince Charming
let's see those talents in action I
can't say no to a face like that I'll go
with you give me some cover fine I'll do
it but I died I'm making sure Walker
Lewis eats both of you first I'll
distract them did I see you guys reach
safe come then I'll try to redirect the
smelly Patrol to give you guys a chance
to spread inside the building when we
get into position I'll signal you then
you can do your thing good luck
oh here we go
[ __ ] I gotta kill this dude I think
that's the [ __ ] at me
[ __ ]
okay let's get the [ __ ] out of here she
says just catch me if I want to die
let's go baby
kill him okay he's kid his kid oh my god
it's time we finish these fools off
no I guess we don't want to eat the cake
yes these will be perfect look
try it out see if it works
gonna need your help on this one kiddo
he's going in you still got your gun
just in case just in case go in there
boy get her down get her bum okay
you say anything oh [ __ ] well [ __ ] go
good job is there more [ __ ] this glass
were survivor grenade does anyone know
that
I'm doing it I thought [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] it's this roller what do you want
I just I got a count
it's the Bible did
when your friends made a lot of noise
out there close by you knew about this
place already yeah you got some guys
just shoot him
you got a group count you plus the two
outside I'm thinking about your group
first
we got to get him well squirt this is
disgusting just shoot him kid you're my
ready for the head
that was a really saddening don't say
that now that's impolite
don't steal I'm not stacked up crazy
this isn't yours squirt perfect this is
great
the press e to annihilate let's go baby
whoa
bad ass in charge that's why I'm talking
about yeah Jesus
Marlon listen to me I am telling you the
place was ransacked it's fine we're an
open geardo ya hater take y'all a while
should the [ __ ] really
Sam Mitch check it out don't forget it
tell us even then actually yeah I give
you food to save me like every day for a
week out of the parameter different
colored eyes her father did he follow
you
nope I shoved him into a pack of
Walker's they took a chunk out of them
Bank how them awesome it was dad who's
that how were you thinking what I did he
would have shot us I know that because
he did shoot us the one thing again
yes stamp it yeah hell's going on here
she took outside the safe zone they saw
someone you know what that means there's
a hungry guy out there looking for food
it's happened before
you can't be serious let's go somewhere
and talk about this whoa second
psychopath I'm sorry okay something
did but
I think
it was risky but it was worth it like
you said we can't lose another kid yeah
he did say that yeah absolutely said
that Annie is a mullet
you'll talk to Brody thanks for the
whole plan you guys should go enjoy it
don't know what that was about
she'll be all right eventually still
guess not make sure this is a one time
before I'm gonna go clean up the episode
the dog shed when I cleaned it okay
that's disgusting
why [ __ ] disgusting
not really
dimes not scary I mean it's sad yeah
being a walker is a lot worse than being
dead
how do you know [ __ ] my bad I doubt it
yeah but it's not know what doesn't
matter
I hope you guys are enjoying it cuz I'm
not getting a chance to so he was
awesome at me she built a place speaking
of her all [ __ ] sadness a bunch of
instigators I know I have something
waiting on the other side some please
see and happy
all of us together looks like a nice
place to wind up my hand oh my god yeah
I can't I can't
what's happening
just-joan yeah baby it's yours got some
okay give me the [ __ ] rough draft and
you get the get copy I get it
oh [ __ ] having this nice
that guy's we defecate break in he's
gonna break in on top of that I've
already scared this kid and likes to be
on top of the bed so it's gonna be bad
everybody knows that it's gonna be bad
yeah it's clearance for sure no two more
minutes good day my house versus not
driving everywhere we're running away
but the ranch was nice too before the
blood this isn't the ranch
do you like it yeah I like you know that
I'm used to
I'll say sure you I really do it's good
to feel safe somewhere there you got a
stay up two minutes more time for sleep
I'll lay down when you blow out the
light
alright give me a minute the bullet I
like right away you lost [ __ ] oh this
one collectibles so used to lugging this
everywhere never knowing when we'd find
any supplies I feel a lot lighter they
put another drawn here hard isn't I the
beholder here you have two water flowers
not these they're fake they never die
never lucky flowers they're not as
pretty
okay we're gonna be antlers
goodnight tight don't let a walker bite
and if they try I never let come on it
right one time bank could work
you
come on man drop the gun Lewis C killed
Brody we can't let her walk away
I got it trust Marlon I just I got it I
always have
he trusted him and now she's dead and he
killed her
goodbye
get bylaws come on dude just drop the
gun
this is how adults do things not us
stand down on a reasonable
it's done it's crazy
you don't understand it all do you
Oh
I made the right call
I saved the lives of everyone in this
[ __ ] school except something
I had to save the rest of you okay I
gave my sister's away why would you do
something like that I trusted you Orlin
they trust me they should have
sacrificed a leader would have
sacrificed himself oh yeah
I wanted to get them
space some kind of rescue honest teds
couldn't I was too afraid
you killed Brody because she knew
he didn't mean to let her
well that is shocking
that is shocking
I know I've betrayed you so Jack
luckily you never have to see me again
I gotta come just let me become a bad
memory
excuse me that
please
fine white
I aimed for the head that's good that's
good
Shay's ass that's episode one done
running pretty good but crazy
you've waited OSHA would do the
wind-down hunting
well as well
that's gonna be different I was trying
to protect my darling you're a lot of
mature I was Connie no should probably
dumped me at the counter evil
Chenoa game rebuff your to excuse your
dorm rooms
you didn't get to know Mitch
I know
okay I know yes thanks for watching guys
that's fun I really fun